this is the Jocko underground podcast
number 24 with Echo Charles
and me Jocko uh I'm going to read
something it's kind of disturbing in a
way
a seven-year-old boy in Taiwan who was
allegedly body slammed 27 times during
Judo practice by both his classmates and
Coach suffered a brain hemorrhage and
was ultimately removed from life life
support
a report said Tuesday
the BBC citing the Taipei Times reported
that the coach has been charged with
assault and using a minor to commit a
crime but his charges would likely be
upgraded to include or be replaced by
injury-causing death the boy reportedly
attended a judo practice in April and
suffered a brain hemorrhage after the
repeated injuries he slipped into a coma
and was on life support for 70 days
I still remember that morning when I
took him to school the unidentified
boy's mother previously told local
Outlets he turned around and said Mama
Goodbye by night he'd become like this
the young victim's Uncle reportedly
videotaped the allegedly violent class
footage of the incident reportedly shows
the boy being thrown by older classmates
acting on orders from the coach
according to the report the coach even
allegedly took a turn
then when the child fell unconscious the
instructor allegedly accused him of
feigning the injury the report said the
report identified the coach by his
surname ho and said investigators
determined he was not a licensed
instructor
hoe was ultimately released on bail
equivalent to 3 500 according to the BBC
if convicted he reportedly faces up to
life in prison
horrible there's another story that
added a little bit more detail that had
come out a little bit later he had only
started taking Judo classes two weeks
prior to the horrific incident after
pleading with his parents to let him try
out the martial art
um after doctor spoke to his family they
agreed to withdraw his life support
hoe was initially released by The
District prosecutor following
questioning who accepted his explanation
that the incident was merely part of
normal training
[Applause]
so there you go
um
by the way I saw I originally picked up
on the story from mcdojo Life
who has an Instagram Channel and who
breaks down a lot of these fake or well
mostly it's fake martial arts but he's
definitely honed in on some abusive
instructors
this is one of them and you know look I
I guess the reason to why did I single
this out first of all because it's awful
I mean obviously it just completely
ridiculous and and when you hear about
this kind of just
man what do you call this I don't know
what the word that I would use to
describe I don't like this type of
person it's like it's bully for sure but
then there's a Next Level bully
and I guess when we start talking about
martial arts and we start talking about
parenting and the kids asking to go and
you know we you and me obviously Echo we
encourage people all the time to get
their kids involved in martial arts and
to get involved martial arts themselves
because of the all the benefits that it
has and then you have a s a piece of
scum like this
that does this so
uh just be just pay attention
just pay attention to who the hell
you're you're giving your kids to and
pay attention watch some of those
classes yourself
mom
and also the people that you're hanging
around maybe it's you that's going this
class that's getting beat down you
shouldn't be getting beat down in a
class especially as a beginner look if
you're in the game and you've been
training for three years you're gonna
have some freaking hard classes for sure
you're not
martial arts training is not always
going to be easy it's going to be a push
but there's a difference between
getting pushed and
getting killed obviously or even getting
injured
uh and then and then listen just for
kids the best thing you can do for kids
is make things fun for them
that's the best thing you can do
the idea that you're going to expose a
kid to this kind of abuse
is it that that somehow is going to help
them is just it's patently wrong it's
kind of like uh you know with exposure
therapy if I take an overexpo if you're
scared of needles and I over expose you
to Needles and it freaks you out you go
backwards you don't get better you get
worse if you're scared of blood and I
over expose you to blood it doesn't get
better it gets worse
so if you expose your kids to something
and you overexpose them to the point
where they're uncomfortable it doesn't
make them better look a little bit
uncomfortable is okay
that's okay as long as that exposure
therapy isn't overwhelming when you
expose people to something where they're
overwhelmed hey it's it's way the
warrior kid right the kid's scared of
water you don't throw them in the water
no you let them look at the water then
you let them touch the water then you
let them wait in the water then you let
them go to his knees then you dunk his
then you let him dunk his head and at
any time if they feel uncomfortable you
let him walk away it's okay see there's
nothing to be afraid of you can go
forward
so that's just a heads up thanks to
mcdojo life for for throwing this out
there but
um maybe getting this out to more people
so you're paying attention
we think we're sometimes we think we're
doing our kids a favor right pushing
them super hard and here they are
so beautiful people out there yeah
you kind of even like as an adult you
kind of run that really like when you go
because there's a there's a huge factor
of intimidation especially for kids like
big time where you know they go into a
judo class we'll say because they just
take Judah when I was a kid
and you go in there and it's like it's
the environment is pretty intimidating
so you just want to like okay I'll just
obey yeah fit in and you don't wanna for
sure don't want to get in trouble you
held that in front of you know it's just
intimidating you know so you're just
gonna go with the flow a lot of the time
and then that can be the case too as an
adult as well if you go into you know a
situation like that where it's like it's
kind of intimidating you're going to try
to mind your p's and q's and do what
they say kind of a thing get through it
and you got to kind of be aware of like
like almost on a moral level like hey
man are these people
are they bullying me right now like is
this right and you're always like
fighting with that because you don't
know the tradition you know you don't
know the tradition of the class of the
school or whatever like the history
whatever and that can be part of the
tradition sometimes and you don't want
to mess with that as well so it can be
freaking hard man but when it comes to
like your kids too it's like there's an
element of actually a huge element it's
like you kind of trust that class with
your kid for sure and it's like shoot if
they're just slamming them like that to
that degree where he's getting knocked
out on them ah
you know this
you hear like a when child molesters get
sent to prison they get like raped
themselves and killed and you are
feeling good about that right this is a
similar thing like I want this guy to
get put into prison with a bunch of
that is a little excerpt of what we are
doing on the Jocko underground podcast
so if you want to continue to listen go
to Jocko underground.com And subscribe
and we're doing this to mitigate our
Reliance on external platforms so we are
not subject to their control and we're
doing it so we can give you more control
more interaction more direct connections
better Communications with us strengthen
this Legion of Troopers that are in the
game with us so thank you it's Jocko
underground.com it costs eight dollars
and 18 cents a month and if you can't
afford to support us we can still
support you just email
audits at Jocko underground.com and
we'll get you taken care of until then
we will see you mobilized
Underground